[Music]
hello there I am John Oliver host of
last week tonight we are still on hiatus
this week and please know that wherever
I am right now I am badly sunburned
even if I've been inside the whole time
I'm still badly Saunders but we wanted
to give a quick back to school video for
the many students who are returning to
school to prepare you for the upcoming
academic year and I will try therefore
not to swear for the next few minutes
but frankly after a year and a half of
being on HBO I honestly don't know if
that is impossible
so whoops so let's go class-by-class
first American history listen the only
thing you need to learn about this is
something that they are almost
definitely not going to teach you and
that is Warren G Harding's love life
which believe me was spectacular
seriously
Google warren g harding penis named
jerry right now and you will not be
disappointed
although to do that you may have to
switch SafeSearch off so let's move
straight on to world history you are
going to hear a lot in school about
european explorers and colonists now as
adults you will realize that these men
will basically genocide a lunatics
possible for now enjoy thinking of them
as thrilling adventurers and discoverers
you will also learn that Africa and Asia
are places but that's about it you will
you will leave school knowing as much
about those two continents as I know
about actor Penn Badgley you'll know
it's something that exists in the world
but you won't be able to give any facts
about it other than the general shape
let's move on to math you're going to be
repeatedly told you need this when you
grow up fatties you will need a
addition subtraction multiplication and
division which where I'm from were
called the original Fab Four but that is
it
I'm an adult with a job and I cannot
remember if a logarithm is some kind of
exponent Kenny Loggins first album or a
method of lumberjack birth control I
don't know
so ignore it just ignore it and move on
biology let's talk about biology you you
may have to dissect a frog this year in
which case if you do the most lasting
lesson will be what frog embalming fluid
smells like you will never forget it
seriously you will forget your first
kiss before that stench leaves your
nostrils let's move on to chemistry this
is going to be disappointing unless you
have a really good teacher you probably
won't even learn how to cook meth and
that's really all anyone's in it for and
finally English class this was my
favorites because it's basically just
essay writing you can't be wrong the
biggest mistake you can make is
forgetting who dies at the end of a book
so we have made a handy guide to who
dies at the end of things so this will
help you for example at the end of of
mice and men
Lenny dies also some rabbits and a woman
with rabbit like qualities at the end of
Romeo and Juliet both Romeo and Juliet
die but you actually don't feel that bad
about it
in the jungle by upton sinclair lots of
animals die and so in a way does the
American Dream in the Great Gatsby
Gatsby George and Tom's mistress all die
and the American Dream does too and at
the end of Death of a Salesman
spoiler alert the salesman dies put in a
plot twist he was the American dream the
whole time you genuinely do not need to
read any of those right now in fact you
basically just graduated your upcoming
high school year
so enjoy your well-earned time off and
join us September the 13th when last
week tonight returns on HBO goodbye
you